veamos si podemos escribir 21 centavos
como un número decimal y te voy a dar
una ayuda intenta escribir este número
como una fracción cuyo denominador es
100 es decir como un número que está en
centésimas a partir de ahí va a ser muy
simple escribirlo como un número decimal
y ya hemos hecho esto antes podemos
obtener una fracción equivalente a
multiplicar por un mismo número el
numerador y el denominador o al dividir
entre un mismo número el numerador y el
denominador veamos cuáles son los
factores comunes 21 es divisible entre 3
y 7 y 1 y 21 por supuesto mientras que
60 es divisible entre 3 entre 20 no es
divisible entre 7 es divisible entre 1
entre 60 pero esos no importan así es
que nos queda claro que podemos dividir
el numerador y denominador entre 3
vamos a hacerlo vamos a obtener una
fracción equivalente al dividir entre 3
numerador y denominador y que nos queda
de esto tenemos que en el numerador va a
ser 21 entre 3
esto es igual a 7 mientras que el
denominador resulta 60 entre 320 así
hemos escrito 21 60 bosch como 720 a vos
y aquí podrías decir oye sal para que
hicimos esto si lo queríamos tener en
términos de centésimas y lo hemos dejado
en términos de 20 a vos resulta que de
alguna manera es más fácil transformar a
centésimas 720 a vos que directamente 21
centavos para ir de 20 a 100 tenemos que
multiplicar por 5 y si ahora hemos
multiplicado con estas partes por 5
también multiplicamos cada una estas
partes por 5 de nueva cuenta estamos
multiplicando tanto el denominador como
el numerador por un mismo número
así en el numerador que nos queda 7 por
5 35 mientras que el denominador resulta
20 por 5 100
déjame escribirlo mejor 35 centésimas y
esto era lo que queríamos hacer escribir
esto en centésimas y para escribir este
número en su notación decimal recordemos
lo siguiente si aquí tenemos el cero en
el lugar de las unidades luego a la
derecha del punto decimal estaría el
lugar de las décimas estas son las
décimas y luego seguiría en lugar de las
centésimas estas son las centésimas así
es que 35 centésimas se denota por 0.35
así es que esto es igual a 0.35 y tú
podrías decir este momento aquí tenemos
el 3 en las décimas aquí vemos que el 5
está en las centésimas pero aquí está el
13 en las décimas porque son estos 35
centésimas
pues bien tres décimas son treinta
centésimas este número es 35 centésimas
otra manera de ver esto es si escribimos
este número vamos a escribir 35
centésimas de la siguiente manera
es 30 sobre 100 30 sobre 100 más 5 sobre
100 más 5 centésimas ahora 30 centésimas
quiero transformarlo a décimas para eso
voy a dividir tanto el numerador como el
denominador entre 10 dividimos entre 10
y que tenemos el numerador me queda 3 y
el denominador me queda 10 3 décimas más
5 centésimas tres décimas más cinco
centésimas es lo que tenemos aquí aquí
tenemos tres décimas este celular de las
décimas y aquí tenemos cinco centésimas
tres décimas más cinco centésimas que
equivalen a 35 centésimas